bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin pour le débat
de la matinale alors il y avait deux
meetings ce week end à lille jusqu'à
8000 personnes et à reims 4000 militants
le même jour à quelques heures
d'intervalle un duel à distance avec le
même thème le pouvoir d'achat et la
défense deux classes moyennes et
populaires écoutez
[Applaudissements]
je propose donc la prime
zéro j'ai pour 0 tab pour augmenter
notre revenus as
tout faux pas nous
pourra accorder une prime chaque année
sans aucune taxe ni aucune charge ni
patronales ni salariales
cette prime cette prime pourra
représenter jusqu'à trois mois de
salaire n'est 13ème 14ème 15ème mois
sans ça
c'est une mesure qui mettra fin au
scandale des salaires aux bases sur
lesquelles baisse des charges
maintenant il veut parler de pouvoir
d'achat ce qu'ils trouvaient méprisant
c'est incroyablement puéril c'est moi
qui ai conçu et théorisé la france d
oublier un voilà pour pour ces deux
meetings ce week-end maxence briques et
des relations extrêmement tendues en ces
derniers jours entre le rassemblement
national et le parti la reconquête
d'eric zemmour à ce meeting marino
peines on est surtout pris à aal
emmanuel macron eric zemmour n'a pas
prononcé lui le nom de marine le pen est
ce que les choses vont s'apaiser maxence
oui helmand s'apaiser pour une simple
raison c'est que contrairement au
traitement que vous faites de cette
élection à mon sens il n'y a pas de tuer
les boers le pen il n'y a qu'à duel des
gros patrons là la famille nationale de
droite n'a aucune raison de voir un duel
entre elles étant donné que nous
poursuivons tous le même objectif qui
est de vaincre la menace macron
maintenant être examinées l'une n'a
jamais montré un quelconque d intérêt
pour la question du pouvoir d'achat il
n'a pas arrêté de faire des propositions
en ce sens en plus de la prime
défiscalisées qui je le rappelle est une
mesure forte pour pouvoir d'achat c'est
à dire que si jamais votre patron vous
donne deux mille euros de prime vous
toucherez 2000 euros le patron de
rattraper les 3500 euros comme c'est le
cas actuellement avec l'urssaf qui prend
tout il avait déjà fait des propositions
en ce sens avant sur la baisse de la csg
qui sont un véritable trait et moi pour
les salaires les plus faibles sur le
remboursement 50 % des frais de
carburant pour les français qui eux
n'auraient les travées avec leur voiture
et qui ne bénéficie pas du remboursement
de bénéficient les transports en commun
actuellement et qui favorise du coup les
populations plutôt urbaine ou encore la
défiscalisation totale des heures
supplémentaires ce sont des mesures qui
sont extrêmement fortes qui vont dans le
sens d'un second qu elle exhume hall de
son aveu de son propre aveu trou même
présenté récente et déçus de nicolas
sarkozy pour travailler plus pour gagner
plus eric zemmour sa philosophie c'est
simple c'est il rend leur argent
français en arrêtant de financer des
dépenses folles qui sont inutiles et
bureaucratiques je prends des exemples
assez simple pour les migrations de
médicale d'état les allocations non
contributives il a pris l'exemple dans
son discours de la chine à qui on a
versé quand même 140 millions d'euros
pendant la crise sanitaire au titre de
l'aide au développement ce qui est un
scandale absolu donc eric zemmour
supprimera toutes ces dépenses inutiles
et notre système social étant ce qu'il
est c'est à dire un système extrêmement
généreux avec avec les français mais
aussi avec le monde entier on pourra
leur rendre cet argent qui va du coup à
l'airé véritablement sur leur compte en
banque et plus sûre je ne sais pas
quelle caisse de l'assurance maladie on
a selon un sondage ipsos 78% des
français qui estiment qu'ils contribuent
plus ce système social de la france qui
n'en reçoivent donc il faut que cette
injustice cette inégalité là s'en aille
et pondent puisse enfin avoir un système
social qui protège véritablement les
français alors comme rick salomon on va
parler du duel après mais sur cette
question du pouvoir d'achat ce que
marine le pen elle à qui on prête à un
profil plus sociale qu'eric zemmour ne
peut se démarquer des propositions du
candidat de la reconquête
mais je crois que tous les candidats qui
s'opposent à emmanuel macron ont fait le
même constat c'est à dire que le pouvoir
d'achat est une des priorités des
français je remarque juste que monsieur
zemmour en septembre et octobre ayem
marine le pen quand elle s'occupait du
cri du pouvoir d'achat il est même dit
je crois qu'il met pas que marine le pen
méprisait les français en parlant
prioritairement du pouvoir d'achat
heureusement aujourd'hui d'ouvrir les
yeux carole tous les candidats méritants
sont bien de reconnaître que les
français aujourd'hui sont préoccupés par
la question du pouvoir d'achat je crois
que tout le monde est bien conscient
mais les mesures proposées par ben ben
je pense d'eux de bons sens et vos mains
et vont plus vers l'est que devant des
français la baisse immédiate de la tva
sur les produits énergétiques sera
immédiate immédiate une baisse de 2,8
euros sur un plein d'essence alors que
effectivement faire rembourser par les
entreprises 50 % sa de coûts du
carburant cela va pénaliser nos
entreprises le petit pme tpe vont se
retrouver complètement prise à la gorge
donc c'est pas possible aux effets de la
prise en charge des charges patronales
par l'état pour les augmentations de
salaires jusqu'à 1,3 fois le smic c'est
une bonne chose parce que là c'est une
augmentation de salaire c'est dire que
le salarié bénéficiera au long terme une
crime vous l'avez une année vous n'avez
pas là des suivantes donc c'est à la
cool unix et c'est vraiment ce n'est
parce que devant des salariés les
salariés ils veulent du long terme une
augmentation de salaire avec prise en
charge des charges patronales sur
sur cinq ans d'un quinquennat cela va
permettre de vraiment redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux salariés cette
question du pouvoir d'achat c'est
vraiment ce qui vous différencie maxence
briquet je vouvoyais réagir
non c'est parce que yen moi je vais
encore une fois je vous dire je n'ai
aucune animosité envers leur assemblée
nationale vont vers marine le pen mais
je souhaitais juste rétablir quelques
vérités
lorsqu'on dit que le le prix des
carburants pour les trajets domicile par
et remboursées par l'entreprise
examinera bien précisé que cette somme
sera déductible de leurs bénéfices nets
imposables donc à partir de là ça ne va
pas poser à chanter dans le foot rien
écouter lorsque vous baisser les taxes
sur le carburant sur les énergies c'est
aussi le contribuable qui va payer
monsieur 1 sauf que la différence c'est
que lorsqu'on fait les calculs lorsque
vous baissez la tva de 20 à 5,5 déjà sa
baisse le prix de l'eau à la pompe que
de 10 centimes et surtout ça coûte 5
milliards aux finances publiques là où
notre mesure déjà sera plus efficace
parce que la baisse effective pour les
salariés sera bien plus importante et en
plus de ça elle sans mon l'autre pour
les finances publiques donc j'ai envie
de dire lorsque vous proposer par
exemple une des mesures qui sont de
l'ordre de la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour les moins de trente ans en
faisant cadeau fiscal énorme à killian
mba paix ou à tous les footballeurs et
en exonérant des gens qui sont en
général sur diplômés des grandes écoles
de ski par un mal du tout au contraire
mais c'est des gens qui vont déjà très
bien gagner leur vie en fait les jeunes
qui sont les plus favorisés ne
toucheront pas ne seront pas les départs
cette thèse ne seront pas et ne seront
pas aidés par cette baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu de l'exonération vue qui
dans tous les cas y danse on exonérer de
base
réponse elle aimerait que salma où je
voudrais qu'on avance dans le débat
pardonnez-moi maxence briquet si oui
mais c'est pour ça que je me suis
briquets a indiqué que la mesure marine
le pen était bonne pour les personnes
qui sortent de grandes écoles parce
qu'effectivement le but c'est de
maintenir en france des gens qui sont
tentés par la départ à l'étranger et oui
nous assumons le fait que tous les
jeunes de moins de 30 ans doivent
bénéficier d'une
suppression de la peau sur le revenu et
effectivement cela tu frappes
ponctuellement les joueurs de football
mais vous savez cet exemple est ridicule
parce que j'entends monsieur mélenchon
prendre le même donc quand vous prenez
les mêmes éléments de langage que
monsieur mélenchon je suis quand même
surpris mais
l'ingénieur sortant d'école seront
attaqués c'est à dire que vous pouvez
prendre le cap du sud ap et puis de
l'autre côté si le ciel est bas p rès
enfance grâce à tester les bons et ben
oui dans l'avenir il n'y aura plus 30
ans il paiera des impôts et ce sera sa
formidable pour la france et sa
apportera
d'autres de vente de dollars apportés
par le paris saint-germain
non cet argument de 2ème map est
vraiment ridicule alors maxence
excentrique et on va continuer si vous
le voulez bien vous parliez de vous
disiez qu'il n'y avait pas de duel entre
le rassemblement national et la
reconquête pourtant il ya une
campagne d'une rare violence verbale en
tout cas la semaine dernière marine le
pen a parlé de nazi dans l'entourage
d'eric zemmour et gilbert collard le
président d'honneur et porte parole de
la reconquête à elle lui a répondu
regarder
il y a les catholiques traditionalistes
les païens et quelques nazis tout cela
ne fait pas une posture présidentielle
les uns nous traite de nazis les autres
qui appartiennent à la guerre des
boutons disent que l'on pût des pieds le
niveau monte comme dirait patrick
sébastien mais il est clair que second
tour il va falloir que l'on se
réconcilient alors la phrase exacte de
gilbert collard sur la réponse de marine
le pen c'est qu'elle va finir présidente
de sos racisme
voilà pour pour la réponse mac maxence
briquet c'est vrai que eric zemmour n'a
pas répondu en tout cas à cette attaque
directement à marine le pen pourquoi
est ce que nous nous parlons français
marine le pen nous cherchons à
rassembler le camp national c'est
l'objectif d'eric zemmour depuis les
débuts de cette campagne il souhaite
l'union des droites marine le pen pour
nous est une femme courageuse qui a mené
des combats importants depuis des années
elle a été en figure de proue pendant
pendant longtemps sur beaucoup de thèmes
mais avec deux fois sa chance marine le
pen et c'est le constat qu'on fait
aujourd'hui le corps national et les
patriots mérite la victoire il ne mérite
pas une énième opposition stérile qui va
durer cinq ans avec huit députés à
l'assemblée nationale nous voulons la
reconquête de notre pays et marine le
pen apparemment à l'air plutôt
préoccupés par le maintien de sa place
et de la pme familiale qu'elle rassemble
nationale qu'elle fait vivre depuis dix
ans donc nous joue encore une fois je
vous dis en a de la tendresse pour les
électeurs de l'assemblée nationale et
pour ceux qui ont été depuis 40 ans s'il
faut le dire avant le rappel ça fait 40
ans que le rassemblement national
existent et ils ont mené des combats qui
sont importants mais aujourd'hui le
ratio national ni les coups de
national du rassemblement d'un sommet où
étiez vous quand nous avions besoin de
vous parce que vous dites qu'on n'a pas
gagné depuis 40 ans et
ce toutes ces années
monsieur nous étions là monsieur nous
étions là mais nous cherchons rassembler
la droite à faire en sorte que le rpr
honnête
et une droite capable de gagner vous
vous êtes tombés dans le piège
mitterrand diack qui constitue la plus
grosse arnaque politique la cinquième
c'est pas une attaque contre vous
monsieur c'est jusqu'au jour on entre on
constate bien que la division des
droites qui a été voulue par françois
mitterrand n'a plus de raison d'être et
que marine le pen
c'est compliqué à distance il faut
parler l'un après l'autre eric sagne
je finis juste et
bien j'aimerais bien juste dire ça le
fait de dire que le piège c'est lille
qui était tendue par la gauche
c'est-à-dire france mi temps à la droite
n'a plus de raison d'être que nous
souhaitons faire de la droite est
aujourd'hui encore une fois eric zemmour
d'attac absolument pas marine le pen on
reconnaît son courage le courage c'était
le sien pendant des années mais
aujourd'hui nous disons de nous
rejoindre parce qu'elle ne peut pas
gagner tout seul et elle veut gagner
toute seule elle ne veut pas la droite
lorsqu'on a dit
verneret avec dlr si nous sommes élus
marine le pen a dit qu'il n'en était pas
question son côté elle est en train de
sectarisme version nationale et nous ne
souhaitons pas ça nous voulons que la
droite s'unissent pour gagner en 2022 et
force est de constater que traiter les
autres de nazis ne va pas dans le bon
sens m avec salma réponse alors dit
zaman le pen la personne des personnes
de nazis elle a juste dit l'a souligné
comique parce que quand monsieur collard
avec marine le pen en 2012 il avait dit
que si certaines personnes ne sulfureuse
rené marine le pen et que lui même
traité de nazi à l'époque il quitterait
le front national à l'époque et ces
personnes aujourd'hui soutiennent eric
zemmour ouvre donc j'attends monsieur
collard le feu m si une partie de la
france a appelé à voter pour eric
zemmour a tant que monsieur collard et
c'est dans l'application est comme ça ça
sera ça sera vraiment très clair c'est
lui qui l'avait même 10 en 2012 moi je
ne fais que répéter les propos de
monsieur monsieur collard aujourd'hui
moi ce que je vois c'est que les
attaques de monsieur zemmour ccc souvent
on voit les mêmes juste avant le
week-end de reims où il y avait un grand
meeting on annonçait 40 conseillers
régionaux qui du rassemblement national
qui devait rejoindre monsieur zemmour au
final 0-0 pas la seule donc voilà c'est
ça les attaques qui sont sournoises et
que cabaret content and
au second tour marine le pen est donnée
quasiment au coude à coude avec la marge
d'erreur
il n'a aucune chance de gagner alors que
marine le pen justement elle est
encadrée site dédié après 3
2 échecs comme vous l'avez dit mais
exactement comme jacques chirac avec
deux échecs dont françois mitterrand
avec deux échecs et bien aujourd'hui
marine le pen
les derniers sondages montrent que eric
zemmour est à 14 % tout comme marine le
pen ils sont au coude à coude et eric
salmon un sondage qui a sorti cela c'est
le forestier toujours le moine le moins
bon pour ce soir et ipsos je crois qui
est toujours le moins le rassemblement
national l'ensemble des autres sondages
mais toujours marine le pen même devant
valérie pécresse parfois avec deux
points devant moi ce que je regarde
surtout ce sont les dynamiques on va
voir au fil du temps moi je pâques le
meeting de marine le pen ou à la fin de
son meeting elle a parlé avec son coeur
aux français pendant 10 minutes voilà
briser l'armure ce devant le dis ce que
je crois que cela va toucher les drones
français parce que au-delà du programme
au delà du fond il ya la forme les
autrefois qu'aujourd'hui marine le pen
est vraiment là chef d'état qu'il faut
pour la france pour rassembler
l'ensemble des français autour d'une
personne qui contrairement emmanuel
macron ne divisera pas les français
demain aujourd'hui je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord il faut mettre un fin
à cette parenthèse macro nist qui a été
catastrophique pour la france monsieur
matheron a passé cinq ans à diviser les
français aujourd'hui marine le pen peut
rassembler l'ensemble des français et
c'est ce qu'elle fera dès le 24 avril
est ce que vous appelez vous aussi weeks
allemand à l'apaisement et peut-être à
s'entendre c'est ce que c'est l'appel
lancé on l'avait vu tout à l'heure par
gilbert collard le soir du le soir du 10
avril nous aurons besoin de tous les
patriotes et moi je demande à monsieur
briquet que fera t-il le soir du 10
avril si monsieur zemmour n'est n'est
pas au second tour appellera-t-il à
voter marine le pen à la réponse en
afrique est alors de trois choses pour
revenir sur la question que vous lui
avez posées à l'origine
pour le coup nous racontait ton s'est
jamais posé la question d'un
affrontement avec leur sauveur national
donc le sujet n'est pas là on n'a pas
lorsque vous disais qu'avec 40
conseillers régionaux qui devait nous
rejoindre enfin c'est pas nous qui
allons les chercher c'était leur
assemblée nationale a montré
suffisamment de fois qu'ils n'étaient
pas capables de gagner des élections
importantes pour que les gens souhaitent
venir chez nous là dessus a pas de
sujets concernant les sondages vous avez
raison si la dynamique qui est
importante et ce sondage là vous donner
il ya une semaine devant valérie
pécresse à 17 points et noah 12 vous en
avez perdu 3 en a gagné deux on est tous
les deux à quatorze l'écart est quand
même suffisamment significatif pour
qu'on voit bien que la dynamique et bien
du côté d'eric zemmour est pas du côté
de marine le pen enfin sur la question
que m'avait posé eric zemmour sera au
second tour donc la question ne se pose
absolument pas comme montpellier à quel
point
conviendrait maxence briquet la maison
mais je moi je moi je peux vous dire
qu'il y sera et on en reparlera les
avait souhaité par une le pen ne sera
pas au second tour on voit que la
dynamique est en train de s'inverser que
les trouve s'infléchissent site marine
le pen face à m je souhaite encore eu
monsieur mais qui ont des sessions
attendez-moi également à
tous les patriots tunis ont gagné donc
il n'ya pas de raison qu'on fasse 120
chambres nationales n'y a pas de raison
qu'on fasse sens et l'air si l'union des
droites avec le rn et avec elle si nous
appellerons tout le monde à nous
rejoindre mais est-ce que vous votre
eric zemmour monsieur est ce que votre
eric zemmour vous
eric salmon réponse allait
donner la mienne j'ai déjà dit que votre
azemmour
refuse de répondre
j'ai joué l'honnêteté si vous le
souhaitez les pas de sujet d'habitude
les gens du ressort national sortent
aussi que marine le pen se consume
entouré cette bonne guerre mais si je
voterai marine le pen si jamais le
second tour une mais elle n'y sera pas
donc que la question se pose pas mais je
suis en rien n'arrête tous les deux
qu'elle est là l asim électorale
concrètement d'eric zemmour actuellement
pour confirmer en tout cas cette
dynamique ce sont les c'est la droite
sioniste principalement
n'y a pas de cible fin de la part d'eric
zemmour notre notre combat c'est la
france et les français donc on va pas
les dragues létalité l'électorat on va
pas essayer de faire de la segmentation
au niveau de la population française la
seule chose qu'on cherche à faire c'est
unir les français autour de combat
commun et qui sont partagées par 70%
d'entre eux la lutte contre
l'immigration et de contre l'insécurité
le retour du pouvoir d'achat l'enjeu
civilisationnel on voit s'effondrer
absolument partout avec la perte de
notre souveraineté énergétique avec une
école qui tombent en lambeaux avec un
système de santé qui est aux abois
toutes ces raisons font que il est
minuit moins 10 km et et philippe de
villiers aujourd'hui non pas aujourd'hui
la samedi dernier pendant son discours
s'est il est encore temps d'agir il
n'est pas trop tard il est en essai en
2022 qui il faut absolument qu'elle
exhibe morgan sinon il sera peut-être
trop tard aymeric salmon la dynamique et
la stratégie pour marine le pen
aujourd'hui c'est c'est plutôt et les
abstentionnistes
oui le notre ennemi c'est emmanuel
macron le principal adversaire c'est
l'abstention parce que aujourd'hui nous
savons que si nous réunissons l'ensemble
de nos électeurs qui sont ils sont
fidèles et parce que quand vous discutez
avec les angles dans la france profonde
on voit que il ya de grandes différences
avec le ce qui se passe sur les réseaux
sociaux sur twitter sur sur facebook et
les français ont un amour surprenant
quand je suis avec marine le pen de voir
l'amour que les français en pour elle et
ce qui compte c'est de combattre cette
ascension de faire en sorte que nos
électeurs se rendent aux urnes
marine le pen
cette guerre fratricide en tout cas
maxence briquet ce qu'elle ne profite
pas à valérie pécresse si on se réfère
évidemment à ce dernier sondage où elle
est donnée à ses ennemis pour cent
encore une fois il n'ya pas de guerre
fratricide enfin je sais pas vous la
voyez en tout cas reconquête on ne parle
absolument pas de ça ça matin quand la
main
non mais enfin on peut avoir des
différends au niveau des idées et des
propositions là dessus il n'y a pas de
sujet fin c'est normal c'est le débat
démocratique on te paye d'accord sur
tout mais de là à parler de duel
fratricide comme s'il voulait tuer
l'autre ses 26 absolument pas
d'actualité et ce absolument pas comme
ça qu'on le perçoit en tout cas ça a été
dit et je le redis c'est emmanuel macron
notre seul adversaire c'est sa politique
c'est tout ce qu'il a fait c'est le
déclassement de la france qui a résulté
des mauvais choix qui ont été les siens
dans toutes les dents tout la politique
qu'il a fait au niveau de notre
souveraineté énergétique la fin du
nucléaire et son retournement de veste
le fait qu'il ait perdu un nombre
incalculable de contrats sur
l'international avec les sous marins
australiens par exemple les mêmes les
rafales avec la suisse le fait qu'il
était incapable de gérer la crise
sanitaire le fait qu pouvoir d'achat des
français a baissé le fait que les impôts
est augmentée tout cela contribue à un
ras-le-bol général des français et nous
nous souhaitons rassembler les français
de droite les abstentionnistes pour
gagner en 2022 avec eric zemmour
tous les français et pas seulement ceux
de droite
on peut prendre à assembler tous les
français à l'élection présidentielle
monsieur vous le savez très bien on
essaye déjà de relancer les buts sinon
gare
à gagner une fois qu'on a gagnant est le
président de tous les français mais pour
gagner il faut rassembler la droite pour
gagner il faut faire 50 % pas 100% oui
mais si vous demandez aux gens s'ils
sont de droite ou de gauche il ya moins
de 50% des gens qui disent qu'ils sont à
droite donc en rassemblant les français
de droite à elle moins de 50%
de droite gauche haut bas en sept bouts
avec eux et c'est là justement les
absences monsieur c'est pour ça que je
dis le
moi mon voisin
ni de droite ni de gauche il hésite
aujourd'hui à voter je ne sais pas pour
qui il va voter
pour
marine le pen tous les français s'ils
veulent sauver la france
une dernière question puisque si je me
réfère évidemment et ce n'est qu'un
sondage assez à ces chiffres 14% pour
les deux ça fait 28 % est ce qu'une
union avant le premier tour serait
envisageable maxence brique est
clairement non pour tout un tas de
raisons fin c'est à dire que ne
serait-ce que logistiquement parlant une
campagne présidentielle c'est
extrêmement lourd tant en termes de
moyens techniques que financiers donc je
doute que ça ait lieu mais nous
l'appelons dans tous les cas donc que la
question n'est pas là c'est à dire que
l'on ne va pas mettre des divisions dans
le camp national et de la droite
patriote pour des questions logistiques
on sait que ce sont d'énormes fringues
je ne pense pas qu'il y aura d'alliance
avant le saut avant le premier tour
pardon mais je l'appelle de tous mes
voeux et j'espère vraiment que marine le
pen fera un choix raisonnable pour la
france et faire en sorte que le corps
national triompher qu'elle ne soit pas
là pour diviser mais bien pour
rassembler le nom de son parti est ce
que vous disiez monsieur justement la
droite et la france ne pourra pas gagner
si elle n'est pas rassemblé au moins
pour faire 50 % en 2022 et nous appelons
à cette union pour vous et moi et
seulement 1 1 un ralliement en tout cas
avant le premier tour sera envisageable
pour marine le pen
maintenant avant le premier tour
l'ensemble des candidats doit être sur
la ligne de départ mme marine le pen et
si on peut parler de ce point sur les
parrainages a toujours dit qu'il fallait
que l'ensemble des candidats qui
souhaitent participer au premier tour
puis sa valeur par l'âge marine le pen a
encore quelques difficultés pour avoir
l'ensemble de ses parrainages et ça
c'est pas normal elle est à combien
marine le pen et bien hier dans une
réunion que nous avions de l'ensemble
des responsables départementaux il nous
a été annoncé qu'il manquait encore une
cinquantaine de parrainage et donc j'ai
moi j'appelle tous les maires de france
à apporter leurs parrainages qui n'est
pas un soutien on rappelle un parrainage
n'est pas d'un soutien à l'ensemble des
candidats que ce soit mais mme le pen
que ce soit monsieur zemmour monsieur
mélenchon qui aussi paraît-il à des
difficultés il faut que chacun des
candidats puissent être sur la ligne de
départ et après à nous de convaincre je
suis entièrement d'accord avec monsieur
briquet sur ce point nous ne sommes pas
en guerre nous sommes là pour convaincre
avec nos petites différences même si sur
le point le jeu des rouges avec lequel
je suis pas d'accord c'est sur ce terme
du dandé droite parce que je pense que
c'est le clivage droite gauche est
complètement galvaudé et qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans un clivage patriots
mondialiste et nous ne sommes pas le nom
de l'ensemble des les gens même de
gauche qui aiment la france j'appelle
même les gens de gauche qui aiment la
france à voter pour marine le pen parce
que c'est là aujourd'hui que que ce fait
le voyage et je suis certain que
monsieur briquet monsieur zemmour aime
la france et même s'ils sont pour
l'union des droites quand marine le pen
sera au second tour j'ai effectivement
je suis certain que monsieur zemmour
appellera à voter pour marine le pen et
c'est une bonne chose mais
tous d'accord c'est entendu merci
beaucoup on n'a plus le temps
malheureusement de poursuivre ce débat
merci en tout cas d'y avoir participé ce
matin en direct dans la matinale d arte
france